there you go
this is a question uh to ask what is the
most beautiful feature in a programming
language
before i ask you let me say like with
python i remember
i saw list comprehensions okay it was
like when i like
really took it in yeah it i don't know i
just
loved it it was like fun to do like it
was fun to do that kind of
um uh it was something about it to be
able to filter through a list
and to create a new list all in a single
line was elegant i could all
get into my head and it just made me um
fall in love with the language so is
there let me ask you a question
uh is there what to use the most
beautiful feature
in uh in a programming languages that
you've ever encountered
in swift maybe and then outside of swift
i think the thing that i like the most
from a programming language
so so i think the thing you have to
think about with the programming
language again what is the goal
you're trying to get people to get
things done quickly
and so you need libraries you need high
quality libraries
and then you need a user base around
them that can assemble them and do cool
things with them right
and so to me the question is what
enables high quality libraries
okay yeah and there's a huge divide in
the world
between libraries who enable high
quality libraries
versus um the ones that put special
stuff in the language
so programming languages that enable
high quality
quality libraries got it so so and what
i mean by that is
expressive libraries that then feel like
a natural integrated part of the
language itself
so um an example this in swift is the
int and float
and also rain string things like this
these are all part of the library
like int is not hard coded into swift
and so what that means is that because
int is just a library thing defined in
the standard library along with strings
and arrays and all the other things that
come with standard library
well hopefully you do like int but
anything that
any language features that you needed to
define int you can also use in your own
types
so if you wanted to find a uh quaternion
or something like this right um well it
doesn't come the standard library
um there's a very special set of people
that care a lot about this
but those people are also important it's
not it's not about classism right it's
not about
the people who care about instant floats
are more important than the people who
care about quaternions
and so to me the beautiful things about
programming languages is when you allow
those communities to build high quality
libraries
that feel native they feel like they're
built into the built into the compiler
without having to be what does it mean
for the int
to be part of not hardcoded
in so is it like how so what isn't
what is an int okay
is just a integer in this case it's like
a you know like a 64-bit integer or
something like this
but so like the 64-bit is hard-coded or
no
no none of that's hard-coded so ins if
you go look at how it's implemented
it's just a struct and swift and so it's
a struct and then how do you add
two structs well you define plus and so
you can define plus on
int well you can define plus on your
thing too you can define
uh int has like an is odd method or
something like that on it and so yeah
you can add methods onto things
yeah uh so you can you can define
operators like how it behaves
yeah that's you is beautiful when there
there's something about the language
which enables
others to create libraries which are um
not hacky yeah they feel they feel
native and so
one of the best examples of this is lisp
right
because in lisp like all the libraries
are basically part of the language right
you write term rewrite systems and
things like this and so
can you as a counter example provide
what makes it
difficult to write a library that's
native is it the python c
well so well so one example i'll give
you two examples um
java and c plus plus or java and c
um they both allow you to find your own
types
but int is hardcoded in the language
okay well why
well in in java for example coming back
to this whole reference semantic value
semantic thing
um int gets passed around by value
yeah but if you if you make if you make
like a pair
or two something like that a complex
number right it's a
it's a class in java and now it gets
passed around by reference by pointer
and so now you lose value semantics
right you lost math
okay well that's not great right if you
if you can do something within why can't
i do with my type
yeah right so that's that's
the the negative side of the thing i
find beautiful is
when you can solve that when you can
have full expressivity
where you as a user of the language have
as much or almost as much power as the
people who implemented all the standard
built-in stuff
because what that enables is that
enables truly beautiful libraries
you know it's kind of weird because i've
gotten used to that
uh that's one i guess other aspect of
programming language design you have to
think
you know the old first principles
thinking like why are we doing it this
way
by the way i mean i remember because
i was thinking about the wallers
operator and i'll ask you about it later
but it hit me that like the equal sign
for assignment
yeah like why are we using the equal
sign
assignment and that's that's not the
only solution right so if you look at
pascal they use colon equals
or assignment and equals for um
for equality and they use like less than
greater than instead of the
not equal yeah like there are other
answers here so but like
and yeah i'd like us ask you all but but
how do you then decide uh to break
convention to say you know what
everybody's doing it wrong we're gonna
do it right
yep so so it's like an roi like return
on investment trade-off right so if you
do something weird
let's just say like not like colon equal
instead of equal for assignment that
would be
weird with today's aesthetic right and
so you'd say
cool this is theoretically better but is
it better in which ways
like what do i get out of that do i
define a way class of bugs well one of
the class of bugs that c has is that you
can use like
you know if x equals without equals
equals f
x equals y yeah right well
turns out you can solve that problem in
lots of ways clang for example
gcc all these compilers will detect that
as a as they likely bug produce a
warning
do they yeah i feel like they didn't or
clang does gcc
didn't and it's like one of the
important things about programming
language design is
like you're literally creating suffering
in the world
okay like like i feel like i mean
one way to see it is the bicycle for the
mind but the other way is to like
minimizing suffering well you have to
decide if it's worth it right and so
let's come back to that okay but um but
if you if you look at this and again
this is where there's a lot of detail
that goes into each of these things
um uh equal and c returns a value
yep that's messed up that allows you say
x equals y
equals z like that works in c yeah um
is it messed up you know well so that
most people think it's messed up i think
it is very by messed up what i mean is
it is very rarely used for good
and it's often used for bugs yeah right
and so
that's that's a good definition yeah you
could use
you know it's a in hindsight this was
not such a great idea right now
one of the things with swift that is
really powerful and one of the reasons
it's actually good
um versus it being full of good ideas is
that um
when when we launched swift one we
announced that it was
public people could use it people could
build apps but it was going to change
and break
okay when swift 2 came out we said hey
it's open source and there's this open
process which
people can help evolve and direct the
language
so the community at large like swift
users can now help shape the language as
it is
and what happened is that part as part
of that process is
a lot of really bad mistakes got taken
out
so for example swift used to have the c
style
plus plus and minus minus operators like
what does it mean when you put it before
versus after right well that got
cargo culted from c into swift early
what's the cargo cult
cargo colton means uh brought forward
without really considering
considering it okay um this may be not
the
most pc term but uh look it up an urban
dictionary
yeah so it got pulled it got pulled into
c without
or it got pulled into swift without very
good consideration
and we went through this process and one
of the first things got ripped out
was plus plus and minus minus because
they lead to confusion
they have very little value over saying
you know x plus equals one
and x plus equals one is way more clear
and so when you're optimizing for
teachability and clarity and
bugs and this multi-dimensional space
that you're looking at
things like that really matter and so
being first principles on
where you're coming from and what you're
trying to achieve and being anchored on
the objective is really important
you